[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos una vez más a
este espacio de canadá en las américas
café la emisión semanal del servicio en
español del radio canadá que les
ofrecemos cada 7 días a través de los
diversos canales de comunicación que
ustedes disponen es decir nuestro sitio
en internet www rc y net punto sea el
canal de youtube que ustedes ya todos
conocen y que frecuentan cada vez más
semana a semana y facebook live que
también está a su disposición para
seguirnos en este reencuentro que les
proponemos para renovar esa relación
ruedan las ruedas del ferrocarril
hasta el momento porque estamos
reaccionando rápidamente y está la
emisión que corresponde al viernes 24 de
mayo del 2019 y en esta ocasión estamos
aquí en el estudio paloma martínez
leonardo gimeno una hola que tal
pablo gómez barrios saludos a todos mi
nombre es luis laborda y hoy tenemos una
invitada que es juliana restrepo a quien
pueden ver en la otra punta de esta mesa
que es colaboradora de la entidad
de la organización hispanidad quebec y
nos viene a hablar de un taller para
emprendedores latinoamericanos que
vienen de realizar esta muy fresquito
todavía nos va a contar todo lo que
ocurrió allí y de esta iniciativa que
supongo yo que será interesante para
todos aquellos
para aquellas personas de origen
latinoamericano que quieran iniciar
proyectos que quieran tener su propia
empresa en marcha que tengan ideas que
quieren concretar y que no saben cómo
hacerlo que sabemos que las ideas muchas
veces abundan pero uno carece de los
contactos del conocimiento de la
información de los consejos e inclusive
que puedan facilitar llevar esos esas
cuestiones a la práctica bueno con
julián entonces vamos a desarrollar la
temática durante una buena parte de
nuestra emisión de hoy
lo cual es una ventaja porque si te
gusta trabajar también está bueno que
este viernes
bueno pues son los temas que les han
llamado la atención a ustedes en estos
últimos días fuera algo que se trata
netamente de actualidad pablo en tu caso
por ejemplo cuál es el tema que te
atrajo que te llamó la atención en estos
días pero insólito soy yo sí soy como
convencional raro a bueno pues me
pareció interesante ver una foto que
apareció por ahí en las redes y que fue
viral que es una foto interesante no sé
si vamos a poder verla en un momento
dado más es de un fotógrafo de ontario
no de columbia británica
no él es de ontario pero la foto fue
tomada en victoria y en un lago él desde
hacía ya cierto tiempo estaba tratando
de tomarle de fotografiar esa águila
cabeza blanca
que que suele o solía estar ahí en ese
paisaje
estuvo varias veces intentándolo y nunca
lo había logrado pero el 4 de mayo
pasado se instaló quizá un poco
demasiado cerca de el lugar donde estaba
el águila de tal forma que el águila
reaccionó y comenzó a volar en su
dirección
entonces no lo lastimó pero le permitió
pues tomar la foto que quería por eso
digo que lástima la lesión si bueno pues
el tipo pues debe tener sangre fría me
imagino pues porque cuando tú ves un
animal como este un ave con una
envergadura inmensa de metro y medio y
que viene hacia ti pues no él se quedó
tranquilo y desde la foto es para los
grafos como tú pues puede ser una idea
soy un tiro con lo mejor ver si quiere
las muestras
si tengo un gato que saque también
estuve como una hora y media en
dirección a ver si lo encuentro
rápidamente
[Música]
con respecto a esta foto mientras
leonardo busca l
el tipo pues se dice que está entre las
10 mejores fotos que él jamás haya
tomado eso pues me pareció interesante y
me pareció insólito bueno y está además
el gato quiere mostrar esa gracia que yo
el gato no me miraba no me miraba no
estuve una hora panza al piso esperando
hasta que en aumentado se sentó se
acomodó y me miró y ahí le saque la foto
y si uno agranda en realidad que no se
puede mucho pero si uno agranda me había
estado reflejo en la pupila del gasto yo
acostado panza el piso sacando la
fotografía para los fotógrafos para los
fotógrafos y yo vuelvo con aves salvajes
porque a mí lo que me llamó la herencia
o salvajes blandos
[Risas]
y que no son urbanas son realmente del
campo y ahora se están paseando por las
ciudades de canadá son pagos pagos
salvajes pagos silvestres o compradores
pidiendo pidiendo
también winnipeg y en mis y sogas los
residentes han visto pavos paseándose
por la calle como si no fuera como
cualquier cosas frescos como la lechuga
como pedro por su casa como pedro por su
casa yo vi otro vídeo que no pude poner
acá porque no tenemos el derecho es un
residente de la región de winnipeg en
que el pago perseguía a la persona y
entonces la persona tenía miedo por la
baja son grandotes
de coraje agarrarlos y meterlos al horno
hasta cuando hasta cuando el pago diga
hasta aquí vamos bien mientras no sé si
este es el caso paloma pero hemos visto
en magna ocasión distintas especies
animales que se están adentrando cada
vez más en las zonas urbanas pero por
una necesidad de supervivencia para
buscar alimento etcétera pudiste ver si
este es el caso o solamente es una
cuestión de que aparecieron ahí nadie
sabe porque están buscando comida están
buscando comida lo que es particular es
que ya tienen varias semanas en las
regiones urbanas de canadá entonces no
es nuevo nuevo como fenómeno ya tienen
algunas semanas pero se siguen no
creería que con la llegada de la
primavera sería más fácil para ellos
encontrar comida en sus regiones
naturales pero parece que no parece que
siguen acercándose a las comunidades
urbanas y bueno parece chistoso pero en
realidad nos habla de una particularidad
de la de este año esperemos que
solamente eso
en esta ocasión se trata de pavos
y de hecho en la semana pasada no les
presenté el vídeo pero había un oso que
se subió a un balcón en set muy cerca de
vancouver y eso es peligroso billete que
sacas a tu hijo al balcón oa tomar el
aire y él tampoco
y además parece mentira que esto ocurre
en un país como este que tiene tanto
territorio que tiene tanto bosque tanto
paisaje casi inexplorado que los
animales tengan que adentrarse en la
ciudad bueno una pequeña delegación para
atacar caminar pero pasaba yo me acuerdo
de haber estado todavía en argentina
preparando los datos y todo el trámite
para venir a canadá y andaba rondando en
los albores de internet andaba rondando
una imagen una foto que decía esto pasa
en
en algunas ciudades canadienses con el
correo y estaba el papel del correo que
decía no pudimos dejarle el paquete
porque había un oso en la puerta de su
casa y era filter digamos era un papel
de correos canadá que no es persona no
se pudo acercar porque había unos o sea
no es nuevo pero igual es bastante más
como con una hora
el tema extra el tema extraño un estudio
bueno ustedes conocen alejandro
jodorowsky
de paloma está hablando tengo fotos de
descentralista bueno según él y
respaldado por el instituto nacional de
ciencias de salud ambiental hay un
estudio que revela que las mujeres
heredan la genética y el temperamento de
parte de su abuela materna
específicamente así dice este y me
parece que el instituto nacional este de
concede en carolina del norte eeuu dice
que las mujeres heredan la información
genética y el temperamento de sus
abuelas el cuadros que explica en el
libro metagenealogía auto-descubrimiento
a través del circo mágico y el árbol
familiar la influencia genética de las
abuelas maternas tienen en las nietas ni
los nombres dice según el chileno los
genes que reciben en el vientre de la
madre provienen directamente de las
abuelas y la información de este estudio
del instituto nacional en ciencia de
salud ambiental corrobora lo que son
decían que las mujeres y el temperamento
digamos que tiene bases científicas la
genética
los hombres en nosotros
[Música]
y ustedes ya nadie habla
bueno y por mi parte quería comentarles
una breve información que también me
llamó la atención el tema de la gente
que atraviesa la frontera entre canadá y
estados unidos ha estado en boga desde
hace ya tiempo desde siempre en realidad
pero en los último en el último año y
medio o dos tomos más preeminencia por
el caso del flujo mayor con mayor
cantidad de gente que intentaba llegar
desde eeuu hacia canadá por pasos
fronterizos que no son los que están
estipulados para ingresar al país y eso
puso el tema de la inmigración ilegal en
la picota una vez más y original de bat
etcétera bueno hubo un señor que no está
muy en claro la información no lo aclara
si es turista o qué pero si se sabe que
es de origen español que intentó
ingresar desde territorio canadiense a
eeuu nadando a través de lo que ustedes
ven hacia las cataratas del iguazú o
catarata arriba me imagino que no
si vas a las cataratas del niágara este
señor tuvo la mala idea de tirarse a las
cataratas para intentar cruzar la
frontera nadando y por supuesto no logró
su objetivo tuvo que ser rescatado por
guardias fronterizos de los estados
unidos y fue detenido porque de hecho
estaba violando una ley y estaba
ingresando o estaba intentando ingresar
eeuu como ilegal en todo caso así que él
junto a dos personas que se presume que
lo ayudaron a cometer esta alocada
empresa fueron detenidos a poquito de
intentar entrar en el territorio
estadounidense cuando todavía estaban
mojados por las aguas las cataratas del
niágara
pero solo usar hacer eso merecería que
le dieran la ciudad
pero yo antes de la semana próxima voy a
presentarles un reportaje porque hay
historias que terminan bien como esta de
la que nos hablas pero hay otras que
terminan mal y no hay muchos casos pero
hay casos de muertes de personas que
atraviesan la frontera ya sea de eeuu y
canadá pero más bien de canadá hacia
eeuu y que les va muy mal que tienen una
experiencia mala que caen en un lago que
está que está demasiado frío etcétera
entonces hubo el caso de un dominicano
del cual vamos a hablar la próxima
semana porque un dominicano perdió la
vida atravesando la frontera ganado
estadounidense con dirección a estados
unidos entonces el puede ser muy
peligroso porque son zonas dicho el
niágara es un lugar donde incluso han
ocurrido accidentes que se ha caído
involuntariamente que ha salido
gravemente herida o incluso ha perdido
la vida es un torrente de una corriente
de agua con con una energía con una
fuerza que hay que como decía de un ave
que tiene muchas agallas hay que estar
muy loco para aplicar
aunque era muy popular en alguna época
lanzarse abajo de las cataratas en todo
tipo de dispositivos en baúles
galones en un montón de cosas
eso fue en una época había pero la gente
solía hacer ese salto de las cataratas
inclusive algunos resultaron heridos
otros muertos aprovechando el fallido
con y hablando de las cataratas del
iguazú a aquellas en argentina hay de
hecho expediciones excursiones que se
hacen a las caídas de agua más
pronunciada yo he hecho algunas de ellas
inclusive astún unos en medios
algunos se mete debajo del torrente de
agua pero las personas que guían las
embarcaciones que llevan a los turistas
saben con mucha precisión dónde entrar
hasta dónde llegar y aun cuando salir
del lugar tirarse a
digamos al cuerpo limpio a nadar sin
semejante caudal de agua a gas o
excelente
antes que nada así como darle los
saludos aquí ya empezamos mis rodillas
nos está mirando leonardo nicole es el
manual rayman dice saludos de desde san
ramón de la nueva orán salta república
argentina el mismo momento sólo entre 3
nicolás manuel nicolás t the rain man si
fue en alguna época cuando nosotros
estábamos en la onda corta nuestro más
joven oyente de la onda corta de de
radio canadá internacional con omar
ortiz uruguayo de colombia un mensaje
también de miguel' rovira dice hola mis
estimados componentes del programa
canadá las américas café un placer
escucharlo su fuerte abrazo muchos 73 y
para todos desde los oyentes desde
barcelona españa
otro de nuestros top fans eso me encanta
con un incógnito articular articular
dice gustavo lucas saludos desde la
ciudad de melo departamento de cerro
largo en uruguay y killen abril también
top fun dice saludos desde nuevo
brunswick canadá y para martínez nos
dice
[Música]
[Risas]
en que se encontraba en españa
y quería practicar su español va a tener
que en un momento dado hacernos un
informe y decirnos guillén nos estás
viendo de cómo te fue en españa estaba
en salamanca entonces pues por ahí dice
el dicho que lo que dios nos dio
salamanca no lo presta pero ella fue a
salamanca para perfeccionar lo que
cierto es que les estamos pidiendo
también la gente que nos envíen vídeos
entonces hitler podría hacernos un
videíto pequeño para que nos muestre
cómo vive y que nos explique cómo
ya ese periodo el vídeo vamos a volver
un poco más tarde porque tenemos
nuevamente un vídeo para mostrarles esta
semana pero ahora vamos a ir como le
decíamos al principio de la emisión con
nuestra invitada la habíamos anunciado
hoy le damos la bienvenida nuevamente a
juliana restrepo que es colaboradora de
hispanidad quebec y decíamos juliana que
ustedes organizaron y llevaron a cabo
esta semana un taller destinado a
emprendedores latinoamericanos contanos
por favor qué es lo que hicieron pues
buenas tardes gracias por la invitación
feliz de estar aquí de contarles y por
intermedio de ustedes llegarán a la
comunidad a nuestra comunidad
latinoamericana donde quiera que esté en
canadá y obviamente en quebec tenemos
una cercanía pues por estar aquí pero
pero aquí hemos llegado yo te decía
atrás de cámaras
hablamos de una colaboración muy cercana
con el equipo de hispania que ve que hoy
se disculpa y nos acompaña de corazón
pero es una sinergia el taller que se
hizo esta semana fue una sinergia de
amigos de organismos y de personas que
queríamos que queremos unir a esta
comunidad que queremos llegar a nuestra
comunidad mi trabajo como te decía es
con repatriación latina en canadá yo soy
gerente comercial de la compañía y es un
trabajo muy social el servicio que
nosotros ofrecemos es un tema muy social
que nos lleva a trabajar de la mano con
organismos como hispanidad quebec y
llegamos a tocar las puertas del alcohol
de de gaulle de emprende entrepreneur de
quebec y son ellos quienes nos abren su
espacio sus puertas y bajo del parkour
de inmigrantes se hace el primer taller
o los dos primeros talleres de
emprendedores uno con él era la se lance
en acero quebec en español nos dimos en
ser ciencias en negocios en jueves que
es bien interesante muchos estamos aquí
incluso había gente recién llegada
habían personas que llevan dos meses
otro día con tres semanas en canadá
entonces fue muy especial ver que
podamos hace nueve años que estaba que
llegué yo a canadá no teníamos como no
teníamos quien nos contará cómo hacer
una empresa aquí ahí los recursos y hay
cantidad de recursos que todavía nos
falta contarle a la gente nos falta que
nuestra comunidad se dé cuenta el taller
fue un taller con una muy buena
asistencia la idea es que queremos
seguir haciéndolos el equipo del alcohol
está muy abierto y pues de pronto nos
estamos moviendo en varios escenarios y
en espacios diferentes pero la idea de
seguir haciendo este tipo de talleres
tuvimos una comunidad latinoamericana
hermosa tuvimos argentinos tuvimos
mexicanos tuvimos peruanos tuvimos
salvadoreños guatemaltecos colombianos
entonces es lindo que logremos llegar y
soltar la responsabilidad en ustedes que
son los que están aquí cada semana para
que encontremos a la gente que existen
organismos con mis páginas que ve que
quiere unir a nuestra comunidad que con
el profesor víctor a armón y ya se han
hecho estudios hispanidad que viene
trabajando hace más de tres años
comunidad latinoamericana de la mano del
profesor armonía de la mano de caf la de
la coalición con latina arte de la
cámara de comercio- latinoamericana de
que bet se ha hecho unos trabajos muy
bonitos e hizo la gran encuesta
latinoamericana y pues este año
enfocamos un poquito y se ha enfocado un
poco el trabajo de hispanidad al tema de
talleres de emprendedores y de unir a
nuestra comunidad veíamos algunas fotos
es el evento que se llevó a cabo el día
miércoles si bien recuerdo y en una de
las fotos digamos que participó un gran
número de personas y la reflexión que
hacíamos también antes de comenzar el
programa es por lo general se habla de
los latinoamericanos como de gente que
llega a cumplir tareas menores a
distintas sociedades no es el caso
específico de canadá pero además en el
caso de la comunidad de latinoamérica
llega continuamente gente de muchísimo
talento y con muchísimas inquietudes que
a veces no tiene esas herramientas que a
las que tú te referías para poder
iniciar su propia empresa para poder
poner en marcha en marcha su propia
empresa
y eso es lo importante de este tipo de
grupos de este tipo de talleres no la
posibilidad de conocer el proceso como
realmente se hace en una sociedad para
el recién llegado para el que está aquí
ese tiempo una sociedad nueva y no sólo
eso sino también para los que ya tienen
su empresa que está en crecimiento y de
hecho habían algunos de nuestros
asociados y de nuestros más grandes
compañeros que era las alianzas de
personas que están ya con su negocio
andando y dicen cómo puedo mejorar mi
negocio igual mi negocio se me creció en
un momento que puedo hacer para que mi
negocio mejore y ahí hay organismos hay
gente que nos puede ayudar a mejorar los
negocios que ya tenemos andando hay
ayudas gubernamentales para apoyar este
tipo de empresarios que ya están en el
camino habían varios también que
estuvieron diciendo mira es que mi
familia tiene negocio en argentina y yo
quiero replicar el negocio acá como algo
entonces son casos muy particulares pero
este tipo de eventos hacen que
los sepan que vamos a tener que tenemos
un camino tenemos un camino y la idea
seguirlos haciendo yo pensaría
idealmente se habla que vamos a intentar
seguir haciendo como mínimo uno al mes o
trimestral decía que hay gente de
distintas procedencias de distintas
nacionalidades supongo que llevar
también distintos proyectos en marcha en
marcha o pronto sea ponerse en marcha
hubo algún perfil en cuanto a proyectos
que aparecieran en este encuentro hubo
alguna tendencia sea qué tipo de
actividades de agentes está buscando
llevar a cabo estaban muy variadas de
hecho teníamos empresarios de
telecomunicaciones
y él es una persona que apoyó mucho el
trabajo del equipo teníamos empresarios
que están haciendo alianzas para
logística y carga hacia latinoamérica
hacia colombia de venezuela teníamos
habían empresarios si quieren o ya han
arrancado algo del tema de café una
importación o es por el café colombiano
café y guatemalteco y alguien de hablo
de café de costa rica
hoy de telas de argentina pero si
entonces si muy variado muy variado
habían otras personas del área de
sistemas y decían que lo que querían era
una plataforma de sistemas pero bien
interesante o sea se oyeron mil ideas
ley mini ideas he hecho también
organismos comunitarios y cuáles son las
principales trabas los principales
escollos que alguien que desee iniciar
un emprendimiento comercial debe
afrontar más allá de este
desconocimiento pues el problema más
frecuente que surge más allá del
conocimiento de las normas oa veces
incluso no manejar perfectamente las
lenguas más allá de eso que es pues el
problema central que debe enfrentar
estos futuros emprendedores pues yo
pienso que y lo que se hablaba ya era un
poco de la el acceso a la información es
que lleguemos a donde debe estar la
información la información está los
organismos están pero no sabemos cómo
llegar allá entonces ese es el canal de
comunicación que quiere abrir spam
quebec y los organismos aliados que
estamos acompañando todo el proceso
social de hispania de hecho se han hecho
seminarios de otro tipo de temas de
temáticas precisamente porque nuestra
comunidad necesita información aquí
nosotros no sabemos lo importante que es
tener un testamento cuando estamos
recién llegados hay muchos que ni
siquiera sabemos cómo se maneja el tema
financiero entonces es estar la
información es el canal será el puente
entre la información y los organismos
que el gobierno del estado organismos no
gubernamentales que están para dar todo
y los latinos o nuestra comunidad que
está ahí perdida es ser un puente ser un
puente y soltar un poco la
responsabilidad entre todos ustedes los
comunicadores que son quienes nos ayudan
a multiplicar la información decía que
la idea es llevar a cabo un encuentro
una vez por mes o más o menos una vez
por mes hay ya una fecha para el próximo
encuentro estamos en eso estamos en eso
estamos en eso
de todas formas pues igual se viene el
verano y en verano no es la mejor época
en la que así se ha encerrado el 17 de
julio que tengamos una nueva fecha yo
nosotros nos encargamos y el equipo se
encarga de comunicarle hacerles llegar
para que ustedes nos ayuden a contarle a
los emprendedores a ustedes que están
allá detrás de las cámaras y no saben
saben que quieren hacer y no no como
aquí estamos nosotros para ayudarles a
hacer el puente entre tantos organismos
que hay y digamos que hay además gran
cantidad de programas que están
destinados a apoyar este tipo de
iniciativas incluso a nivel financiero
sí claro y financiamiento público algo
muchos hicimos financiamiento hay
organismos que están financiando a
empresas que sean de mujeres empresas
que sean emprendedores que tengan menos
de 35 años emprendedores que tengan
una área específica o sea hay organismos
que están financiando todo el llegara a
quien nos puede mostrar cuáles son esos
organismos está la información está ahí
todo está tenemos que salvo para
aquellos que quieran poner un vector a
[Risas]
[Música]
latinoamérica y es un negocio de mucho
riesgo entonces las empresas quedan yo
conozco porque uno con gente que ha
intentado y que abra cualquier otra cosa
menos un restaurante
si es un restaurant uno tiene que tener
digamos un un apoyo financiero extra
para poder hacerlo no necesariamente con
esto pero hay un montón de lugares donde
se puede buscar dinero para proyectos
muy específicas
voy a preguntar la dirección electrónica
del organismo donde la gente puede ir a
buscar más información no manera de
contactar
hispania que tiene su correo electrónico
su página facebook
en la mente hispanidad pelea que es
lograr encontrar de todas formas si no
los organismos aliados como por ejemplo
repatriación latina que se encarga de
compartir y acompañar todos los eventos
también allí si todo el tiempo o
nuestras páginas personales de liana
jaramillo que es la directora de
hispanidad que ve claudia sarrazín y que
es compatriotas y argentinas que te
oliver
yo juliana restrepo nosotros nos
encargamos de compartirlo como decía la
semana pasada hoy el programa y lo
estuve viendo
angela muchas veces ponemos entonces más
que el letrero del organismo estamos las
caras para ayudar a multiplicar estas
horas en la presentación escrita que ya
he preparado en que está todavía en
línea ya coloque algún link que para que
la gente que esté interesada pueda
contactarse con ustedes de manera más
eficiente pablo si no quería simplemente
preguntarle a juliana o sea porque la
idea es
decías preparar un taller por mes de
formación lo haría siempre en el mismo
lugar o se cambia de lugar podríamos
estar pensando en cambiar también buscar
de pronto lugares diferentes el alcohol
nos dejó sus puertas abiertas y de hecho
la sede me pareció muy buena se sale con
la école de entre menor de quebec la
escuela necesarios emprendedores de que
está acá en boulevard pues habían cerca
suicida pero sí sí la idea es también de
pronto moverlo supongo que durante la
semana probablemente la gente pericias
en un taller en la vall tendrían toda la
comunidad que te cerca de ese punto en
euros y mal pero poder ya además de el
objetivo del taller es informar que la
gente de la comunidad se dé cuenta que
existen organismos pero también la idea
de fondo es hacer un poquito de redes de
contacto y eso era el objetivo uno de
los objetivos y de verdad se logró y
además nos lo explicaba una
en el primer taller es que cualquier
empresario el que quiera arrancar un
negocio el que quiera emprender necesita
redes de contactos
solos no podemos tenemos que hacer
aliados tenemos que hacer sinergias
tenemos que hacer amigos y sobre el
camino crecer nuestra comunidad lo que
decía angela con lo del tema la casa de
las américas nuestra comunidad necesita
unirse y y de verdad es yo sé yo he
sentido el proceso que se ha hecho con
repatriación la tiene en canadá ha sido
hace tres años y tres años y medio y
hemos estado viendo eso viendo muy
chévere muy rico ver que la comunidad
está toda el que está emprendiendo
quiere buscar a otros que han emprendido
de estar en ese proceso es un proceso de
organización que creo que poco a poco se
va dando desde que estoy aquí cada vez
más lo hemos comentado entre nosotros
alguna vez cada vez más se escucha
hablar español en la calle esa presencia
que se da en la calle debe darse su
organización y creo que poco a poco esto
se va logrando lo reflejamos la semana
pasada como vienen tus referías los
reflejamos ahora con la actividad
de españa que de que esta convocatoria a
todos los emprendedores a que salgan de
ese aislamiento ya que se unan para
darse la posibilidad de llevar a cabo de
concretar sus proyectos sus iniciativas
y darle la posibilidad a otros también
que están en una misma sintonía a
sumarse a proyectos en marcha oa iniciar
su propio derrotero acá demos por último
no te vas a ir pero para ir cerrando la
conversación en términos generales al
menos que no se trata solamente un gesto
voluntarista esto ha sido organizado con
gente que tiene experiencias que ha
hecho ya el camino y que puede comunicar
esa experiencia que puede trasladar lo
que ha aprendido en su propia carne
digamos a los que tienen la necesidad de
iniciar su proceso de una manera muy
práctica no es cierto no es solamente
una cuestión de venga que nos vamos a
unir y llamar y ahí vemos que hace nada
no no
hispania ha trabajado muy de la mano de
las personas que saben
el estudiar la comunidad latinoamericana
de cerca con los estudios que ha hecho
ya el profesor armón y que todo el mundo
lo conoce y que sabemos que es una
persona totalmente seria ahora a
acercarnos a los miembros del alcohol
que el alcohol está abierta para eso y
sencillamente han ayudado a muchísimos
latinoamericanos a ir haciendo sus
empresas hacer sus sueños realidad y
acompañar porque son ellos quienes nos
empiezan a dirigir a dirigir pero sobre
todo con respecto a lo que la gente de
la comunidad es para que no conozca al
profesor victor harmonie
hay un formato largo un artículo en
formato largo que yo leo
en el sitio internet sobre el trabajo
igual se está hablando en este momento
latinoamericana así que para aquellos
que estén interesados en ver de qué se
trata pueden ir a nuestro sitio buscar
en la unsl a la pestaña de formatos
largos ya vean encontrar en los
anteriores profundo los primeros el que
hizo leonora con respecto a este estudio
de víctor armas muy gracias julia nada
aunque no te vas vamos a dar quedarte en
el resto de los pocos minutos que nos
quedan para terminar nuestra emisión
mientras tanto les propongo a ustedes
que renovemos esa convocatoria que
hacemos hace ya unas semanas todos junto
a la que el público nos envíe sus vídeos
como les hemos dicho la semana pasada y
en las anteriores ocasiones
estamos esperando estamos ansiosos de
que ustedes nos envíen los vídeos que
graban que filman en sus lugares de
residencia para mostrarnos el entorno en
el cual ustedes desarrollan sus vidas
cotidianas
con el recorte que ustedes quieran con
la idea central que ustedes quieran no
tienen por qué ser vídeos extensos
pueden ser muy pocos segundos
hoy casi a 1 viniendo para que vean cómo
es desde las afueras de mostrar luego
las afueras de montreal tomar el tren
de afuera del centro
y no lo hice porque estaba lloviendo
el teléfono más veloz de montreal es el
señor
fuego lo ha hecho como la semana pasada
un nuevo vídeo para mostrarnos que pablo
bueno mira es que muy cerca de acá de la
casa del edificio de radio canadá que
está en la calle rené levecq la calle
siguiente la paralela ar en el bec es la
calle está en catering que vamos a ver
acá en el vídeo nosotros estábamos allá
al fondo y esta es la calle se encadenen
que vamos a ver y que se ha decorado
durante muchos años durante varios años
de la forma en que ustedes lo ven a que
con esto seguir landas de distintos
colores
hay de hecho sólo con los colores del
arco iris porque eso que están viendo es
una parte de lo que se llama acá
el barrio gay de la ciudad de montreal
que está concentrada en que está
concentrado en ese lugar entonces bueno
es algo así no que queremos que nuestros
oyentes nos envíen mostrarnos un
lugarcito de su ciudad de de su calle
algo que les parezca interesante y bueno
pues nosotros los pasaremos aquí
aprovechamos para decir disculpa pablo
que esa calle que acabó nos basa en
catering es una calle que está ubicada
en pleno centro de montreal que cada
verano se cierra el tránsito vehicular
se convierten en importantes tramos
desde sant y ver creado un barry hasta
la calle papi no es aquí son varias
cuadras sumaríamos efectivamente y que
está decorada como bien vos decías
cuáles son esos motivos que este es el
último año que el autor el autor ha
dicho lo escuché casualmente de días
pasados en una entrevista que hicieron
en la radio en francés que va a ser el
último año porque esas guirnaldas están
hechas en plástico y por lo tanto se
degradan
y que ya es el momento de reemplazar
tienen más vida entonces se las va a
retirar y muy probablemente no tiene
otro tipo de concepto efectivamente
aunque todavía no está definido pero ese
va a ser el último es que va a ser el
último año en el que ese tipo de
decorado va a estar puesto pero sanz
cateterismo y se tramos sí señor bueno
tengo saludos a saber que pasamos a otra
cosa exacto dice javier gonzález
nungaray y quiero expresar mi
agradecimiento a todo el componente de
la redacción en español de radio canal
internacional por los conocimientos que
he adquirido por medio estos programas
semanales cordiales 73 desde mi tierra a
guadalajara méxico paloma también
compartió bueno el facebook de
hispanidad quebec para que puedan ir a
ver y a verificar todos los datos que
hemos estado ofreciendo en durante el
programa de hoy javier gonzález nungaray
dice un saludo también para juliana
restrepo guild en abril dice dónde
podemos mandar los vídeos muy buenas
preguntas los puede mandar por facebook
si quieren al mismo lugar que estamos
ahora digamos en este mismo
como se dice en español la conversación
en la conversación o bien mandarlo a
nuestra
dirección de correo electrónico amlat a
m
como latino l resident punto o sea
también puede mandarlos ahí nosotros los
recuperamos los ponemos en youtube y
después los ponemos durante el programa
hubo uno de nuestros oyentes
o de nuestros escuchas veedores porque
ya no podemos decir completamente
oyentes puesto que no estamos en la onda
corta abrazo las nuevas tecnologías la
cámara que nos había enviado un día y un
vídeo y ya no se extravió y yo le mandé
un mensaje preguntándole que a dónde lo
había enviado y tampoco recibimos bueno
entonces esperamos que no nos conteste y
yo quería agregar con respecto a guild
en abril que no se escucha ya en new
brunswick que ella me corrigió y me dijo
que estaba en granada
por favor si último último nada en él si
remitir y darse saludos a veces y
santana do livramento brasil
saludos en los escasos 6 minutos 20
segundos que nos quedan
[Música]
regresiva vamos a presentarles los
algunos los temas que hemos estado
trabajando a lo largo de esta semana el
tema que destacamos cada semana el tema
que cada autor les recomienda para que
ustedes ingresen en ese torrente de
información y tienen el servicio español
de radio pero muy rápidamente se rebalsa
bueno yo voy a hablar de un tema que no
es tan agradable pero que tiene doble
era en el momento interrogatorio es un
interrogatorio que están denunciando
porque una joven indígena
y fue a denunciar una agresión sexual a
la policía y la policía en el 2012 a un
vídeo que acaban de hacer público pero
que tuvo lugar en el año 2012 esta chica
fue a presentar esta denuncia por
agresión sexual y en lo que se ve en ese
vídeo es el policía interrogando la
haciéndole preguntas con respecto a la
supuesta agresión sexual que lleva a
denunciar y la actitud del policía fue
terrible porque le dijo que si le
pregunto que si en realidad había sido
una agresión sexual lo que si realmente
ella no había estado un poco cómplice de
la situación provocativa la estuvo
digamos un poco acusando de haber ido y
acostando por haber sido parte de esto
que ya estaba denunciando entonces el
vídeo fue fue puesto público fue hecho
público por los abogados de esta chica
que nuevamente tenía 16 años y que ahora
claro más
más madura dijo porque me sucedió eso no
debía haberme sucedido voy a denunciar
al policía y voy a denunciar a la
policía de la región de columbia
británica pero no me acuerdo exactamente
qué es o de ciudad creo que es que lo
una que lo una en columbia británica
entonces de eso de ese tema lo puse
porque creo que es importante hablar de
eso porque muchas mujeres no no quieren
ir a denunciar algún tipo de agresión
sexual del cual habrían sido víctimas
por miedo a ser tratadas de la manera
que fue tratada este niño derecho y es
difícil en el caso de las mujeres dijo
este hacer ese tipo de denuncia porque
te toma agallas justamente entonces hay
que hacerlo por lo de esta semana el
tema que voy a destacar louis es un
informe que salió justamente esta semana
del instituto de quebec que se llama
umbrales de la inmigración en quebec
análisis de las incidencias demográficas
y económicas entonces este es un estudio
que hizo
en esta institución el instituto de
quebec en el que se planea 4 presenta 4
escenarios en cuanto a lo que respecta a
la inmigración es con el número de
inmigrantes que debería recibir la
provincia de québec que el nuevo primer
ministro desea pasar a 40.000 a partir
de este año entonces ese es un análisis
interesante en el que dice que entre más
inmigrantes se reciba finalmente el
mejor es para quebec por varios factores
económicos políticos y sociales entonces
ahí está el reportaje y los invito a
escucharlos y lo que dicen básicamente
para terminar es que el desafío es
integrarlos económicamente entonces
venimos a cerrar el tema que tú trataba
de hacer muchísimas veces eso también
está disponible está en línea desde ayer
y lo voy a comentar lo voy a leer para
que sepan rápido en realidad la unesco y
su publicó un informe en el cual
arremete contra los asistentes
alexa siri de los teléfonos todos los
asistente vocales porque es tan bueno es
justamente los más famosos y populares
tienen nombres femeninos y están
configurados con voces femeninas por
defecto y a partir de este hecho único
decidió estudiar el impacto de esta
configuración y de estas características
porque podría tener una representación
rara de la mujer en el día de hoy a
grandes rasgos el informe que es
realmente extenso sugiere que la
feminización de estos sistemas propenden
a acentuar los estereotipos machistas y
esto bueno en realidad nace del artículo
se llama blues if aykut que sonrojarían
si pudiera este es una de las respuestas
que decir y el de apoyo particularmente
cuando uno lo trata mal cuando uno le
dice alguna la trata mal o la califica
de pe
suspensivos en mujer y es la lista y me
sonrojaría ella dice sir y dice que en
realidad se puede configurar como voz
masculina también pero la unesco dice
que es por una cuestión de que los
programadores y la gente que está a
cargo del ente génesis artificial son
aproximadamente un 80 85 por ciento
blancos y hombres ese material bastar en
línea a partir de mañana
y tú louis la gorda pero en el poco
tiempo que queda en el minuto 10
segundos que quedan en especial instante
no un tema un tema muy importante creo
yo para todos los inmigrantes y para
quienes se encuentren en proceso de
conseguir un estatus formal en canadá ha
habido un fallo de la justicia
canadiense que les reconoce a
trabajadores temporales yo dije en
guatemalteco el derecho al seguro de
desempleo del seguro de desempleo son
trabajadores temporales que fueron
traídos a canadá por una empresa que le
les prometió una determinada carga
horaria no cumplió al tener menos
trabajo
recurrieron a otros servicios que les
fueron ofrecidos y entonces cuando
quisieron pedir el seguro de desempleo
les dijeron que no porque habían violado
las leyes vigentes en el país
ese fallo va a hacer historia los invito
a ver el material que ya está en línea y
que hemos difundido incluso a través de
facebook como me dijo más temprano
español y que crea precedente a
cualquiera va a crear ruido no nos queda
más tiempo muchísimas gracias a todos
por haber estado una vez más con
nosotros
con este emprendimiento y hasta la
semana que viene chau adiós